Transcriber: Uğur Baştuğ
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Herkese merhaba, ben Utku.
Orta sınıf bir öğretmen ailenin
ortalama bir çocuğu
olarak taşrada doğmuşum.
Taşrada büyüdüm.
Memeden kesilmem gereken zamanda
memeden kesilmişim.
Konuşmaya başlamam gereken zamanda
konuşmaya başlamışım.
Yürümeye başlamam gereken zamanda da
yürümeye başlamışım.
Her şey çok normal,
her şey çok sıradan ortalamayken
2 buçuk yaşında,
bundan 33 yıl evvel,
bundan gerçekten 33 yıl evvel,
bir anda konuşmam peltekleşmeye başlamış,
bazı sesleri çıkaramaz olmuşum.
Yürürken tökezlemeye başlamışım.
Başlarda çok üzerine düşmemişler.
çünkü teyzem bizi ziyarete gelmiş,
yeni yılda, yeni yıldan bir hafta önce,
bundan gerçekten 33 yıl evvel.
Ona şımarıklık yaptığımı
sanmışlar başlarda.
Ama bu tökezleme hâli düşmeye,
konuşamama durumu iyiden iyiye
hiç konuşamaz hâle gelmeye başlayınca
bir sorun olduğunu
anlamışlar ve beni hastaneye götürmüşler,
bir hekim bakmış.
Tahmin ettiklerinden daha büyük bir
problem olduğunu ve olabileceğini,
bu yüzden de daha uzman bir ekibin,
uzman bir hekimin
bakması gerektiğini söylemiş
ve beni üniversite hastanesine sevk etmiş.
Apar topar üniversite
hastanesine gitmişiz.
Bu bir problemin başlaması,
ondan sonra hastane, üniversite,
hastanesi süresi böyle birkaç gün.
O birkaç gün içerisinde
artık iyice konuşamaz,
yürüyemez, hatta boynumu tutamaz
olmuşum; çocuk felci.
Şöyle bir sahne var.
Anlattıkları benim de gözümde,
son söyleyebildiğim kelimeler:
Dayı, dayı, dayı, dayı, dayı.
Dayımı sayıklamışım, dayım uzakta.
Dayımı çağırmışlar.
Şöyle bir şey düşünün:
Bir hastane odası, bir yatak.
Yatakta 2 buçuk yaşında
bir kız çocuğu bedeni.
Kapı açılıyor, bedenimi çeviremiyorum,
kafamı çeviremiyorum,
dayımı görüyorum, dayı diyemiyorum.
Sadece gözbebeklerimi çevirebiliyorum.
Pıt, bir damla yaş, bu kadar.
Çok kısa bir süre içerisinde
bu hâle gelmişim.
Bir gün iyice fenalaşmışım, artık böyle,
hayati tehlikeye doğru gitmeye başlamış.
Günün geç saatlerinde beni apar
topar operasyona almışlar.
Operasyona girerken de hekimler demiş ki,
tabii bütün aile hastanede,
“Burada kalmanıza gerek yok.
Eve gitseniz, dinlerseniz daha iyi olacak.
Bu uzun süren bir operasyon olabilir,
masada kalabilir.
Bu yüzden de hani burada kalmasanız
daha iyi olur,”
şeklinde konuşmuş.
Başlarda kabul etmemişler.
Bilhassa annemi göndermek istemişler.
Başlarda kabul etmemişler
ama sonra, yani,
orada durmanın da bir anlamı
olmadığını düşünerek eve gitmişler.
Eve gitmek dinlenmek, uyumak
anlamına gelmiyor elbette.
Telefon başında beklemişler.
Sabah beş, sabah beşe kadar beklemişler.
Bir telefon çalıyor,
“Alo” değil, “Utku yaşıyor,” diyorlar.
Oh, evde bir bayram havası.
Ama, hekimler her zaman
temkinlidir, biliyorsunuz.
Yaşadı ama yürüyemeyebilir,
konuşamayabilir demişler.
Tekrar ediyorum:
Yürüyemeyebilir, konuşamayabilir.
Burada, minik adımlarla
size kendi hikâyemi anlatıyorum
ve bunun çok heyecan verici
olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Bana bunu sağlayanlar, öncelikle tabii
operasyon, akabinde fizik tedavi
süresince öncelikle hekimler, hemşireler,
sağlık çalışanları, sonra ailem.
Günler, aylar, hatta yıl, yıllar.
Bana bunu sağlayan
öncelikle bilim, akabinde
emek ve sabır ve en nihayetinde ortalama
hayatıma geri dönmüşüm.
Benim ailem politik bir aile.
Bizde akşam yemekleri ana haber
bültenlerine denk gelir.
Biz politika konuşuruz.
Gün içerisinde haber kanalları
sürekli açık olur.
Son zamanlar haber yayınları, tabii.
Bir kulağımız orada.
Çünkü biz kendimizden başka herkesin
acısını acımız yaptık.
Dünyanın öbür ucunda bir insanın gözyaşı
bile içimizi parçalamaya yetti.
Mesela, sadece nar yediği için
hayatını dört yaşında kaybeden Saliha,
sadece nar yediği için,
börtü böcek falan öldürmek için
atılan o “tarım ilaçları” dediğimiz
tarım zehirleri;
narın kabuğundan, narın meyvesine sızıyor,
bütün aileyi zehirliyor.
Saliha’nın minik bedeni
kaldıramadığı için Saliha’yı kaybediyoruz.
Saliha’yı tanımıyorum,
ve hiç tanıyamayacağım.
Ama onun haberi içimi parçaladı.
Saliha bir üretici ailesinden gelmiyor.
Tüketici ailesinden geliyor.
Hepinizin olduğu gibi.
Tamam, tüketici ailelerin çocukları böyle.
Üretici ailelerin çocukları nasıl?
Buradan da bir örnek vereyim size,
hiç güzel olmayan bir örnek.
Bir Zehirsiz Sofralar konferansında,
bir araştırma grubunun
içerisindeki hekim anlatmıştı.
Onun çalışmasını sizinle paylaşacağım.
Biliyorsunuz Harran, pamuk üretimi
yapılan bir bölge.
Pamuk en çok tarım zehiri kullanılan
tarım ürünlerinden bir tanesi.
Harran’da yapılan bir çalışmada, pamuk
sezonundan hemen evvel bahar aylarında
orada çalışan üreticiler, tarım
işçilerinin sağlık kontrolleri yapılıyor,
taramaları yapılıyor.
Sonra pamuk sezonundan sonra yaklaşık 3
ay sonra yine aynı kişilerin
sağlık taramaları yapılıyor.
Sadece 3 ay içerisinde gözle görülür bir
hasar tespit ediyorlar bedenlerinde.
Bilhassa solunum yollarında.
Şimdi bu tarım işçileri,
yetişkin bireyler,
orada çalışmayı kabul ettiler diyelim.
Bunu biliyorlardı diyelim.
Peki onların çocukları?
O tarım işçileri,
üreticiler, evlerine akşam gittiklerinde
sadece kıyafetleriyle taşıdıkları tarım
zehirleri ile çocuklarını zehirliyorlar.
Hep birlikte zehirliyoruz.
Şimdi benim yürümemi ve konuşmamı
sağlayan kişilerin,
işte sağlık çalışanlarının
ailem, bunların bir kısmının çocuğu var,
annemler, bir kısmının
çocuğu yok biliyorum.
Bir kısmının çocuğu var
mı yok mu bilmiyorum.
Bildiğim tek bir şey var.
Bir çocuğun yaşama hakkını savunmak
için çocuğumuz olmasına gerek yok.
Peki.
Utku, sen ne yapıyorsun?
Bunun için bir şey yapıyor musun?
Ben ortalama hayatımı yaşamaya
devam ediyorum.
Ama bu kez taşrada değil kentte,
bir apartman dairesinde.
Sıradan bir apartman dairesi.
Ekolojik besleniyorum.
Yerel tohumdan tarım zehirsiz,
gübresiz besleniyorum.
Zehirsiz temizleniyorum.
Temiz giyiniyorum.
Yani adil ve etik üretimle üretilen
giysileri giyiyorum.
Evimde bir çöp kovam yok.
Sosyal girişimciyim, içerik üreticisiyim
ve çevre aktivistiyim.
Evimde çöp kovamın olmaması
beni ilginç yapan şey, biliyorum.
Evimde çöp kovam yok çünkü
çöpe atacak bir şey yok.
Yani çöpe ne atılırdı, hatırlamıyorum.
Bana sürekli tüketmemi söyleyen
bu hızlı tüketim kültürünü,
bence kültürsüzlüğünü, kabul etmiyorum.
Almadığım için atmıyorum.
Bugün kullandığım bir karton
bardağın mikroplastiklerinin,
ben öldükten çok sonra dahi gezegende
kalacağını biliyorum.
Yanlış söylemedim,
yanlış duymadınız.
Karton bardaktaki mikroplastikler,
tek kullanımlık petrokimya
türü plastik kullanmıyorum.
Kullanmadığım için atmıyorum.
Kullan, at- kullanma, atma.
Bir gıdanın ne kadar zor zahmet
üretildiğini biliyorum.
Gıdamın her bir zerresine
kıymet veriyorum.
Evet yeteri kadar alıyorum, ihtiyacım
kadar doğru, israf da etmiyorum.
Doğru.
Birçok kişinin çöp olarak gördüğü
kabukları, sapları dahi
soframa dahil ediyorum.
Bu bizim kültürümüzde var.
Biz sübyeyi kavun çekirdeğinden yaparız.
Atamadığım için de, çöp kovasına
ihtiyacım yok tabii.
Az miktarda kalan organik atığı
içine atıyorum, komposto yapıyorum.
Yani onları nitelikli bir toprak
hâline getiriyorum.
Ekolojik besleniyorum
çünkü ben bir nar yiyeceğim diye
bir çocuğun zehirlenmesini,
ölmesini kabul edemiyorum.
Ekolojik besleniyorum çünkü zehirsiz
üretim yapmanın
ne kadar zor olduğunu biliyorum
ve o üreticiye şunu demek istiyorum:
Ben buradayım, sen yeter ki üretmeye
devam et, ben varım
ve bunu yaparken de eşime, dostuma,
herkese söylüyorum.
Zehirsiz nar, zehirsiz nar,
zehirsiz nar;
herkese söylüyorum.
Arkadaşlarıma söylüyorum,
iş arkadaşlarıma söylüyorum.
İlkokul arkadaşlarıma söylüyorum,
iş arkadaşlarıma- herkese söylüyorum.
Takipçilerime söylüyorum
sosyal medyadaki,
kurumlarda verdiğim
eğitimlerde söylüyorum.
Bu konuşmayı hazırlarken konu
komşuya epeyce anlatmış oldum.
Herkese istiyorum ki zehirsiz nar
niye yesinler, onları anlatayım.
Hep birlikte zehirsiz nar
yemeye başlayalım.
Biz bu bahçedeki üreticiye
garanti verelim, sonra biraz daha
büyüyelim diğer bahçedeki üreticilere de
garanti verelim
ve herkes zehirsiz nar üretmeye başlasın
çünkü istiyorum ki çocuklar zehirlenmesin.
Hiçbirimiz zehirlenmeyelim,
hiçbir şey zehirlenmesin.
Ülkemizin bereketli toprakları dediğimiz
bu yalan var ya aslı şöyle:
ülkemizin bereketsiz tozları.
Ülke topraklarımızın yüzde 88′inde
sağlıklı bir toprakta bulunması gereken
mikroorganizma miktarı
yüzde 2'nin altında.
Biz tarım literatüründe biz bunu
toprak değil toz diyoruz.
Mikroorganizma, mesela bakteri
gibi şeyler ne yaparlar?
Bu topraktaki mineralleri
meyveye verirler.
Vitaminleri, meyveyi verirler ya da
vitamin yapmasını sağlarlar.
Yani fasulyenin hak ettiği magnezyum
üzerinde tutabilmesi için
o bakteriye ihtiyacımız var.
Arama motoruna yazıyoruz:
Fasulyede ne kadar magnezyum var?
Karşımıza çıkan o rakam eğer sağlıklı bir
toprağımız yoksa çok da doğru değil yani.
Bizim de tabii ki
o fasulyeyi tükettiğimizde,
hak ettiğimiz magnezyumu alabilmemiz için
o bakteriye ihtiyacımız var.
Tabii fasulyenin hak ettiği bir magnezyum
olabilmesi için tek şartımız toprak mı?
Hayır değil, tohum da
çünkü biz tohumdan vazgeçtik.
Biz ne zaman ki atalık ve yerel
tohumlarımızdan vazgeçtik,
bunun yerine kısır dediğimiz
hibrit tohumları koyduk,
işte o gün kaybettik.
Tohum kaynaklı mineral ve vitamin
kayıpları en çok B vitamini
ve demirde rastlanmış.
B vitamini ve demir, hepimizin
eksikliği olan şeyler.
Tohum firmalarının aynı zamanda fenni
gübre ve aynı zamanda tarım zehri
ve aynı zamanda gıda takviyesi satıyor
olması ilginç bir tesadüf.
Biz gıdamızı nitelikli üretemiyoruz.
Hak ettiğimiz mineral vitaminleri
biz alamıyoruz.
Üzerine zehirleniyoruz.
Börtü böcek, bakteri, sürüngen, arı
önümüze ne gelirse
tarım zehirleriyle onları öldürüyoruz.
Aynı zamanda bize emanet edilen toprakları
toz hâline getiriyoruz.
Elimizden kayıp gitmesine izin veriyoruz.
İdareten doymaktansa beslenebiliriz.
Birbirimize sarılıp gezegeni
onarabiliriz.
Toprağı sağlıklı hâle getirip iklim
krizini tersine çevirebiliriz.
Yapmanız gereken şey çok basit.
Tüketim alışkanlıklarımızı
minicik değiştirmek.
Minicik, minicik.
Mesela bu hafta.
Yeni yıl sofralarımız için
meyve sebze alacağız.
Zehirsiz nar alabiliriz.
Nar berekettir, güzeldir.
Yeni yıl sofralarına bereket getirir.
Zehirsiz nar alırken tabii yanımızda
file de taşırsak iyi olur.
Önümüzdeki hafta da zehirsiz
nar alabiliriz.
Önümüzdeki hafta da
zehirsiz nar alabiliriz.
Bunu yaparken de eşimize, dostumuza,
herkese bunu neden
yaptığımızı söyleyebiliriz.
Hatta belki birlikte alabiliriz.
Alışveriş grubu kurarız.
Ben biliyorum.
Benzer şartlarda yaşadığımız için sizin
de etrafınızda zehirsiz nar alabileceğiniz
yerler olduğunu biliyorum.
Ama diyelim ki yok.
Bunun için ne yapabiliriz?
Yerel yönetimimizin kapısını çalarız.
Yerel yönetimimize üretici
pazarları istiyorum diyebiliriz.
Ekolojik pazarlar istiyorum, organik
pazarlar istiyorum diyebiliriz.
Bunun için varlar.
Yerel yönetimimizin kapısını çalmışken
mahallemde kompost alanları istiyorum
da dersek çok güzel olur
çünkü organik atıklarımızı nitelikli bir
toprak hâline getirirsek harika olur.
Mahallede kompost alanları.
Tabii sadece yerel yönetimler mi, hayır.
Devlet de devletimizden de
isteyebileceklerimiz var.
Teşviklerini, desteklerini, kendi
tohumunu koruyan üreticiye
vermelerini isteyebiliriz.
Zehirsiz nar üreten üreticiye
Bunun için varlar.
Tabii kapısını çalmışken
tek kullanımlık plastikler yasaklansın,
aynı zamanda yenilenebilir
enerji kaynaklarına da geçilsin
dersek çok güzel olur.
Çok yani çok denedik biz.
Utku, sen geliyorken, biz
dönüyorduk diyorsanız
bir de bunu deneyelim diyorum.
Çünkü --
Bunu yapabiliriz, biliyorum.
Bu hayatın bana ikinci bir şans
olduğunun farkındayım.
Bana bunu veren, bunu sağlayan, yaşamımı,
konuşmamı yürümemi sağlayan bu kişilere,
sağlık çalışanlarına,
aileme ve aynı zamanda
bana bu toprakları
emanet edenlere borcum var.
Ben yolumdayım.
Bana eşlik eder misiniz?
Herkes ve her şey için.
(Alkış)